Tony's with us in North Carolina hey
Tony welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
Dave um bill laughing oh you're a loser
for comment I got a trademark that oh
I'll probably get me in trouble so you
never know what's up okay so I have five
debt two cars two student loans and a
credit card all equally 40 grand $1,200
a month in payments I'm on baby step two
I have a house with $90,000 of equity so
why can't I take some of that pay that
off my payment will only go up by 150 my
current mortgage is 1300 it'll go to
1450 don't you need to clean the mess up
not move the mess into something and
sweep it on the road and try to hide it
but I feel like I could with an extra
$900 a month that I'll be able to save I
could pay off the mortgage in no time
then you could help set it out then you
could pay off the debt in no time
but I'm paying it's not all interest not
all interest you're paying primarily
principle you have $40,000 in debt and
your household income is what 80,000 so
how quickly are you gonna pay off 40,000
it's just tough with the 1168 every
month I have to pay at all these no no
no you make 80,000 a year how long is it
gonna take you to pay 40,000 making 80 a
year just do that math 20 a year is two
years 40 a year is one year leaving you
40 to live on how many kids three what's
your house and what my house being right
now is 1,300 okay all right yeah there's
not a whole lot left over that's the
problem we're not doing a written budget
yeah and that's true too yeah so let's
get your written budget going get your
every dollar app download it takes you
about 10 minutes to build this out and
you're gonna see because here's the
thing
40,000 deducted from 80,000
leaves 40,000 you probably after taxes
can't make it on that pay your house
payment and raise three kids that's
probably not real so you're probably not
doing this in one year but forty twenty
thousand deducted from eighty thousand
that's doing this in your sleep that
ought to be that ought to be a hot knife
through butter and so let's try two
thousand dollars a month going towards
your debts and that hat that's twenty
four thousand dollars a year that has
you out of debt in about what twenty
months true and that's what you do we do
not want to move this over to the house
all we're doing is treating the symptom
not the problem the problem has been
buying crap you can't afford and
overspending and not living with a
budget we all have done that so you're
not different it's not bad thing it's
horrible but it's not going to make you
a bad person it just means that you guys
have been lazy and a mishandled money
which makes you like an American right I
mean we all have done this so but this
whole thing of this whole Ramsey
movement is about us growing up and it's
about adults devise a plan and follow
what children do what feels good so
you're not gonna buy anything ever again
that you can't write a check for if you
can't pay cash for it you can't buy it
the rest of your life you are done with
debt and by the time you get through
this hard twenty months I'm getting
ready to put you through beans and rice
rice and beans you're gonna be convinced
I'm right you don't want any more debt
it's no fun and you can do this so get
with your wife tonight put the little
ones to bed get the budget out look at
the every dollar app download it
pull the computer and do it on your
laptop you can do it on your phone takes
about ten minutes to lay that budget out
and you're gonna go where has this money
all been going you'll feel like you got
a raise when you start doing the budget
and then you attack these debts smallest
to largest no we are not going to sweep
them under the rug by refinancing them
into the mortgage and acting like
they're not there you may want to sell
in a car if you have an expensive car
and that makes you may want to sell a
car that's possible too